الكثير من اساطير الكوميديا الذين طالما
اضحكون من قلوبنا نكتشف لاحقا صراعهم مع
الاكتئاب وكان خيطا رفيعا هناك يفصل ما
بين الضحك والماساه ايقونه الكوميديا جيم
كيري خاض معركه شرسه مع الاكتئاب سنوات
يقول انه تغلب على المرض بالروحانيه وتجنب
المشروبات الكحليه وتعاطي المخدرات احد
ابرز الوجوه في هوليود ومن رواد الكتابه
والاخراج الكوميدي عانى من الاكتئاب
لثلاثه عقود ووضف الفكاهه في معظم اعماله
كمحاوله
للتغلبيه
الكاتب والممثل الكوميدي الامريكي تعيش مع
الاكتئاب لاربعين عاما يقول ان الاعراض
ظهرت عليه عندما كان في السادسه من عمره
ايضا اصيب الكوميديا الامريكي المخضرم
لاري ديفيد بالاكتئاب في السبعينيات
ووقتها لم يكن لديه من ما يكفي الاستشاره
طبيب لكن على عكسيه تغلب على الازمه مبكرا
مع دخوله عالم ستاند اب كوميدي